much like stunning thank you I think you
could actually get married in this dress
like no I was like oh my god I'm gonna
wear white we gonna talk about that but
no I just it was the first one's right
on I was like done I gotta see the ring
let me see that right oh my does go with
the dress look at that gorgeous it's a
little big so I have to wear my other
ring with it right now I have to get it
size but I did I wanted to wear today so
of course you did brand-new tell me how
he did it or what you can't tell me tell
me all about it oh he's memorable
romantic it was in the Dubai Desert he
was just he was awesome before everybody
gets engaged in Dubai Desert Dubai
Desert yeah did he get down on one knee
yes yes of course he did the whole thing
it was all very he had been planning for
like six months yeah did he rehearse and
everything he had to rehearse some stuff
that happened and I wasn't very
memorable did you cry when you got
proposed to umm yes I cried with
laughter so flapping so hard and then it
turned into a cry but yeah why were you
laughing I don't know I'd laugh when I
get nervous and then yeah it was a lot
of fun did you expect it or it was like
it oh really or though surprised not do
not expect it